britain is starting a four-day weekend
to celebrate the 70-year reign of queen
elizabeth this platinum jubilee includes
events throughout the uk that started
with a traditional military parade in
london this morning the 96 year old
queen and her family got a close look at
the festivities holly williams is in
london talking to people along the
parade route holly williams good morning
good morning this was a very british
military parade here they call it
trooping the color with traditions
dating back centuries the mood here was
jubilant with a huge cheer for the queen
when she emerged onto the balcony of
buckingham palace
nobody does pomp and circumstance quite
like the british
over 1200 soldiers marching in formation
lots of bare-skinned hats
the royal children in an open carriage
[Applause]
and two princes on horseback
some here even slept on the street to
get a front row seat without the queen
britain would be britain
but she makes it great
on saturday night there'll be a pop
concert at buckingham palace headlined
by diana ross and on sunday street
parties across the nation a giant thank
you from the british public to their
queen
[Applause]
they are thanking her for an historic
grain
stability continuity
leadership
at 96 the queens looked frail in recent
months last year she lost her beloved
husband prince philip but she's still
overwhelmingly popular with approval
ratings politicians can only dream of
we're from cbs news
we asked people from all walks of life
in the uk what the platinum jubilee
means to them it is a massive thank you
to her i mean she the queen has given us
her life really it's amazing like to
celebrate her and her reign over all
these years yeah i love her she's
beautiful
in a sign of her advanced years this is
the first time the queen hasn't reviewed
the troops herself delegating the task
to her son prince charles alongside
grandson prince william prince harry and
his wife megan are here for the
celebrations it'll be her first public
appearance in the uk since they moved to
the u.s all members of the royal family
are absolute prose when it comes to
being in the public eye they know that
the world's media are going to be honed
in on every single bit of body language
between them and i'm sure they'll put on
a show of total harmony
we understand the queen is hosting a
lunch today for members of the royal
family inside buckingham palace and we
assume that harry and megan are
attending gail
i think that's a really good assumption
holly williams thank you
i love that the people love the queen so
much you guys that she is so well
respected i love that they get dressed
up and when we were there to cover harry
and megan's wedding people camped out
overnight as they did this time even
knowing that they might not even see her
they just want to be in her presence in
any kind of way what does the one lady
say britain would be britain but with
the queen she makes it great
to be so loved is so nice she deserves
all those accolades